I texted my boyfriend and he was like
well actually earlier Annie was like I'm
going to switch over the laundry for you
cuz I have to wash a load of clothes and
I was like oh okay she has my t-shirt
like she absolutely ransacked the
laundry and took my t-shirt I think we
got we convinced them to let us or let
somebody else who lived with us search
their drawers or something and she was
laying in bed and she sat up and the
cover fell down and she had my t-shirt
on N during the argument yeah yeah no I
don't have it she had it on while she's
saying I don't have your T-shirt she
sits up the covers drop and she's
wearing it yeah and it's like a
very it's a distinct t-shirt and she has
it sounds like some a stalker would
do if they live with
you the Honeydew with y'all subscribe
[Music]
today